you're watching us like special from the
2017 British Academy games Awards here's
what's in store fee this week the
blockbuster action title with eight
nominations but did Uncharted 4 take the
best award on the ninth the woman at the
top of the country's games trade body
tells me why she doesn't like being
called a gamer and BAFTA may have spoken
but what did our swipe reviewer make it
the best game category this year welcome
to swipe from perhaps the biggest night
in the British gaming industry's
calendar the BAFTA games are rules
they're all about honoring that talent
behind the titles of the last year the
people who actually make the games
here's Chris with the highlights and the
BAFTA for best game goes to is their
apathy and uncharted 4 it came as little
surprised that uncharted 4 took the top
prize at the BAFTA games Awards the
blockbuster adventure title was widely
expected to win
it features cinematic gameplay sequences
and a storyline that spans several years
and continents and its creators say the
evolution of the industry has helped
them push boundaries
last decade that's incredible his last
decade I mean a lot has really changed I
think at the beginning last decade
people including us we're just starting
to make realistic looking games we were
able to start really creating character
driven narratives that had not only
realistic characters but able to have
realistic performances on it of course
there is more to video games than
development treasure voice actors helped
bring the characters to life as close to
me as any character I've ever played and
when you when you have to do something
over ten years it's a good thing - when
we started this literally ten years ago
Amy Hennig the creator asked me to put
his when they cast me put as much of me
into the character as possible sense of
humor that kind of thing so aside from
the ridiculous upper body strength I'm
pretty much pretty close to the guy and
it's not just about the big-budget
Triple A games independent titles and
breakthrough actor also recognized at
the ceremony inside the eerie puzzle
platformer developed by indie studio
play dead took home four Awards on the
night more than any other title and Best
British game went to over cooked which
was made by a two-man team meanwhile
that dragon cancer won the prize for
game innovation it deals with
bereavement and was inspired by the
creator's own experiences following the
loss of their four-year-old son to
cancer our life with Joel was hard but
it was really beautiful
and so when we thought about creating a
game that would become the only legacy
he would have the legacy we chose and he
could not we created a game that was
hard to play but we believed it was
beautiful I don't think that we're the
first were certainly not the first but
we're among a class of games that are
telling more personal stories that
happened to trigger emotions like
empathy and in dealing with grief in
dealing with sorrow and and having to
bear witness to those things in life
that aren't always fun and they aren't
always the pastimes with the
things that change us the most this
year's Baptists featured a real mix of
different games with success coming to
companies both big and small so even if
awards don't necessarily make much
difference to all developers at least
the ceremony provides an opportunity to
showcase the variety of the industry
Chris Creegan Sky News now we're gonna
step away from BAFTA glory for just a
minute to round up what else has been
going on in the world of tech this week
members of the public have started
testing a driverless vehicle in London a
prototype shuttle pod has been moving
around pedestrianised areas in Greenwich
with no brake pedal or steering wheel
the temporary trial is part of a project
to see how people respond to the
experience scientists at the University
of Manchester have discovered a way to
sieve seawater and turn it into drinking
water using a membrane made of graphene
researchers were able to remove salt
from the water and make it safe to drink
AOL confirmed its merging with Yahoo the
two internet firms will form a new joint
company called oath his parent company
will be Verizon one of America's biggest
communications firm it's thought nearly
half of UK households are frustrated
with poor broadband consumer group which
surveyed over 2000 households with 46
percent reporting problems with their
broadband based on the population that
equals around 12.5 million households
now tonight is all about the BAFTAs but
this whole week has been a key one for
the British games industry because it's
also been London Games Festival a little
earlier I managed to have a quick chat
with the woman at the top of the UK's
interactive entertainment trade body and
I began by asking her if people still
underestimate the video games industry I
think people do underestimate it I mean
we're faster growing than film and music
globally consumers spend over 4 billion
pounds in 2016 and gains 1 in 3 people
play 2 billion players worldwide so
we're absolutely massive economic
powerhouse but we're a huge cultural
powerhouse what do you think needs to
change so that video games get the same
recognition as their movie and music
counterparts I mean I think some people
would argue that we do have the
recognition and again BAFTA as a charity
recognizing games just as much as they
recognize film and TVs great sign but I
think it's around sometimes it's the way
that the media communicates about games
particularly to parents and to teachers
who might not consider using games in
the classroom or who might not you know
know about the different kinds of
fantastic games that they can play
together as a family
I think Pokemon Gogh actually did which
is one of the nominated games tonight
that did actually change a lot of
perceptions with parents and with the
media but I think you know generally
there needs to be more kind of cultural
support for games you see the film
industry the TV industry benefits from
public funding to help new ideas new
directors new developers could benefit
from that if we had that kind of support
as well do you think people who don't
play games just don't get it
I think it's a weird one I think there's
a real cultural bias still with games
and and I think if you say are you a
gamer most people will say no I say I
don't like the term gamer but I play
games just as much as I read books I
watch films I watch TV so I think you
know I think it's changing but I think
some sometimes people assume that games
are just for kids in fact you know
people who play games are in the average
ages in their mid-30s so London games
first of all why does the capital need a
Games Festival you know the UK is the
birthplace in the cradle of the games
industry with the sixth largest consumer
market in the world and we're really the
home of development in Europe London has
this real kind of hotbed of talent we
also have the best university courses we
have such an amazing creative economy
with the film industry TV advertising
architecture so this huge creativity
London and the Games Festival really
does try and shine that international
spotlight on London as a gateway to the
rest of the UK and indeed to Europe and
in a post brexit well what's going to
change I'm looking forward to the games
that are going to come out around
breakfast I think for us it's really
about explaining to government and
really pushing in negotiations for a
real friction-free immigration system we
need to be able to hire the best talent
globally
wherever they are if anyone who didn't
get why you laughed about games coming
out around brexit time would you explain
that I'm really games are really good at
picking up on issues and games can be
comedy they can be parodies and game
developers and the games industry is
really I think really good at kind of
making games that reflect the world
around them and politics is no different
this year's category for best game was a
biggie a real mix of titles and while I
know we've already told you who want it
we still think it's worth you knowing
about some of the other nominees from
that category is our reviewer Lydia so
six years after the first game called
limbo came out we kind of have a bit of
a sequel something calls inside and it
just took the industry by storm last
year because of its attention to detail
it's a side scroller where you control a
boy basically going from left to right
until the game says stop but what's
really cool about inside is some of the
things that did in times of games design
so it had something called procedural
animation where when the boy was moving
his moves kind of roll in for one
another and it's such a fluid way that
we've not seen in other games dust
particle physics you should see the way
that a floating girl's hair moves in the
water
it is stunning and just in terms of
design and that attention to detail it's
well deserved the nomination tonight
last year the first-person shooter genre
was hired and over what came in and
completely shook things up it's made by
Blizzard and these guys are the guys who
made world Warcraft so they're well
versed in has big online multiplayer
game
and that's what they brought the
first-person shooter genre but in
overwatch you have a choice of loads of
different characters and it's about
battling for different points you might
have a payload that you're pushing it to
the end of a level or controlling
different zones and what's really cool
about this game is those characters
themselves more so than any other
triple-a game that we've guys heads ibly
diverse we've got different sexualities
different genders did someone call a
doctor different regions and kind of
countries are represented and that's
really really awesome to be in such a
popular triple-a game
the first titanfall was one of the first
exclusives on xbox and it did okay with
fans but it didn't go down super well
mostly because it had a lack of a story
campaign transferring authorization to
pilot titanfall to completely redress it
and it didn't just read a dress it it
blew it out the park
the story of titanfall 2 is brilliant it
sprawls over nine chapters you're
playing a guy called Jack who has this
huge Titan that he kind of unexpectedly
gets twinned with and one of the joys of
the game is learning and watching their
relationship grow on top of that you
also just have gorgeous that investor's
going from jungles lush and green to
military outposts there's just so much
variety in the gameplay and the story
and some real creativity those one
particular level stands out where you
kind of go back and forwards in time so
that you might go one second you're
trying to take out some troops and the
next minute you're going back to the
same location
years in the past and you're able to
like reset your location it's a really
really creative approach to level design
and it just made the game that bit more
popular
well that's it run the British Academy
games awards for another year I'll be
back next week with more swipe I hope
you can join us then and in the meantime
follow us on Twitter
that's a new swipe let's see what we get
up to you throughout the week bye bye